die online enzyklopädie wikipedia hat
den zugang zu wissen revolutioniert das
ambitionierte ziel sämtliche
informationen über die welt der
allgemeinheit bereitzustellen
christian rickerts ist im vorstand der
deutschen sektion von wickel media dem
verein hinter wikipedia
er zieht bilanz die wikipedia hat klar
gemacht das ist byebye wissen ja nicht
nur um das konsumieren von wissen geht
sondern auch um das teilen von wissen um
sich zu vermehren geschrieben werden die
artikel von freiwilligen fast 6000
menschen sind regelmäßig in der
deutschen version aktiv sie korrigieren
auch inhalte und rechtschreibung einer
von ihnen martin roesch der 28-jährige
arbeitet schon seit zehn jahren
ehrenamtlich für wikipedia wie peter ist
für mich das sinnvollste hobby der welt
zum 1
ich beschäftige mich mit wissen mit
informationen kann selbst etwas dadurch
lernen und anderen informationen
weitergeben
das ist ganz altruistisch quasi gedacht
ich gebe etwas und partizipiere daran
die rund 70.000 freiwilligen weltweit
haben eine der meistbesuchten seiten im
netz erstellt wichtig für den erfolg der
wahrheitsgehalt der artikel auch er wird
von der gemeinschaft überwacht dafür hat
sie sich ein komplexes regelwerk
auferlegt das gemeinschaftsprojekt
wikipedia beschäftigt auch die
wissenschaft
für den betriebswirt leonardo steht fest
das portal hat den umgang mit
informationen verändern wie verschiedene
vergleichsstudien zwischen khedira und
traditionellen enzyklopädien zeigen ist
es so in beiden fällen finden sich
oftmals fehler um schaffen
ungenauigkeiten
ich glaube der große vorteil von
wikipedia ist das da jedem klar ist dass
da verschiedenen weiteren mitgeschrieben
haben und dass man das prinzip mit
vorsicht genießen muss
während bei klassischen enzyklopädien
man das irgendwie selten angezeigt was
da drin gestanden
doch es gibt auch kritikpunkte zum
beispiel die aggressive spendensammlung
von wikipedia der verein nimmt weit mehr
ein als er für die wikipedia seiten
benötigt
damit sollen ein finanzielles polster
aufgebaut und weitere gemeinschaftliche
online-portale finanziert werden zum
beispiel wikipedia commons ein
lizenzfreies bild ton und text portal
die zitat datenbank wikitude
oder wickie data das frei zugängliche
datensätze sammelt und verfügbar macht
ein weiteres problem der autoren schwund
das komplexe regelwerk ist nicht
jedermanns sache
viele erstnutzer steigen nach kurzer
zeit genervt aus die anzahl der aktiven
wikipedianer ist rückläufig in der
deutschen und englischen version um bis
zu 40 prozent
es ist so eines der ziele für 2016 wo
wir uns halt auch überlegt haben wie
kann man das noch einfacher machen wie
kann man das noch attraktiver machen
da auch in der wikipedia mitzumachen und
mitzudiskutieren
zahlreiche anwendungen greifen auf die
freien informationen der wikimedia
projekte zu wikipedia
hier können user individuelle
zeitleisten zu bestimmten themen
erstellen
oder wickie galaxy dass wikipedia
artikel samt verlinkungen als
sternensystem anzeigt
wikipedia hat auf jeden fall neu
definiert was eine inselgruppe dies und
enzyklopädisches wissen in einem maße
breit unter allgemeinheit zugänglich
gemacht das wäre vor 15 jahren noch
völlig undenkbar gewesen
und auch in den kommenden jahren will
die wikipedia-community großes leisten
oder viel zu tun würde ich sagen wir
haben noch wenn man mal schaut es gibt
eine sammlung der wikipedia welche
artikel könnten noch geschrieben werden
das sind noch ungefähr 100 millionen es
es ist viel zu tun
einiges ist schon geschafft wikipedia
hat den herkömmlichen enzyklopädien den
rang abgelaufen und viel weltwissen
bereits zugänglich gemacht